en el último vídeo hablamos del núcleo
de helio que contiene dos protones y dos
neutrones
de hecho los protones y neutrones en el
núcleo se les conoce como núcleo nes muy
bien estos son núcleo nes y vamos a
utilizar este término varias veces en
este vídeo así que de hecho aquí tenemos
una digamos una imagen del núcleo verdad
que tiene dos protones y dos neutrones y
sabemos que es estable ok a pesar de que
sabemos que las cargas iguales se
repelen verdad estas dos cargas que son
iguales se repelen
digamos la una con la otra y esa es la
fuerza electrostáticas quizás le vamos a
escribir eso esa fuerza es la fuerza
electrostática electrostática
muy bien fuerza electrostática sí es
cierto que el núcleo es estable entonces
debe existir otra cosa que está
manteniendo el núcleo junto verdad ya
eso es a lo que conocemos como a la
fuerza nuclear fuerte muy bien eso que
mantiene digamos unido al núcleo es la
fuerza nuclear fuerte y por supuesto
para que esto se mantenga unido es una
fuerza que es mayor a la fuerza
electrostática la fuerza nuclear fuerte
actúa solo a distancias cortas y de
hecho actúa entre todos los núcleos es
por ejemplo una interacción entre protón
y protón es exactamente igual que la
interacción entre protones y neutrones
que de hecho es igual a la interacción
entre dos neutrones muy bien y de hecho
podríamos adentrarnos en más detalle
digamos hablando de la fuerza nuclear
fuerte pero no es no es el punto de este
vídeo ok el punto que vamos a trabajar
aquí es que el núcleo es estable y vamos
a pensar por qué es que el núcleo es
estable así que pensemos primero en el
número atómico que en este caso sería
qué nos dice el número de protones
verdad el número de protones lo vamos a
representar con la letra zeta muy bien
mientras que el número de neutrones lo
vamos a representar con la letra n
mayúscula ok y vamos a enfocarnos en la
proporción que hay entre neutrones y
protones así que consideremos la
proporción que hay digamos entre
neutrones y protones muy bien y que para
este caso que tenemos del núcleo de
helio 4 serían dos neutrones dividido
entre dos protones y eso nos da una
proporción igual a 1 verdad entonces lo
que sabemos hasta ahora es que si el
número de protones es más chico que 20
entonces una condición para que el
núcleo se estable es que la proporción
entre núcleos perdón entre neutrones y
protones tiene que ser 1 para que el
núcleo sea estable en otras palabras el
núcleo debe tener el mismo número de
protones que d
neutrones muy bien y así es como se
mantiene estable el núcleo en este caso
por supuesto para el núcleo de helio 4
es estable
ahora bien pensemos qué ocurre con el
núcleo de carbono 14 que es uno de los
ejemplos más típicos pensemos en el
núcleo de carbono 14 verdad el número
atómico del carbono 14 es 6 tenemos aquí
el número atómico que 6 eso nos dice que
tenemos 6 protones en el núcleo verdad
ahora si queremos calcular el número de
neutrones tenemos que restar 6 a 14 y
eso nos da 8 neutrones verdad al número
de masa le restamos el número atómico
así que pensemos cuál sería la
proporción que hay entre neutrones y
protones es verdad como pensemos en este
cociente en este caso tendremos 8
neutrones y lo vamos a dividir entre 6
protones verdad y esto por supuesto es
un número más grande que uno es un
número mayor que 1 y por lo tanto
tenemos un núcleo ine
muy bien el núcleo del carbono-14 es
inestable es radioactivo verdad y de
hecho va a experimentar decaimiento
espontáneo y va a tratar de obtener una
mejor proporción entre neutrones y
protones así que fijémonos en la
ecuación nuclear que representa el
decaimiento radiactivo o espontáneo del
carbono 14
la ecuación sería la siguiente tenemos
carbono 14 verdad
nos da un electrón verdad más nitrógeno
14 verdad y ahí tenemos nuestra ecuación
nuclear y por supuesto cuando escribimos
ecuaciones nucleares sólo representamos
los núcleos así que por ejemplo del lado
izquierdo tenemos el carbono 14 el
núcleo de carbono 14 verdad solo estamos
hablando de núcleos y por lo tanto sólo
estamos hablando de 6 protones verdad en
este caso tendremos seis protones y ocho
neutrones de hecho vamos a escribir que
tenemos seis protones verdad y lo que
ocurre aquí es que el núcleo de carbono
14 va a ceder un electrón lo cual es
bastante raro cierto y vamos a hablar
más un poquito más de esto en el próximo
vídeo es una conversión que está
gobernada por la fuerza nuclear débil
pero bueno nosotros sabemos que un
electrón tiene una carga negativa verdad
y por eso así estamos de notando lo en
esta parte entonces un electrón tiene
una carga negativa
ahí está la carga negativa del electrón
y el carbono 14 o al menos el núcleo del
carbono 14 se va a convertir en un
núcleo de nitrógeno 14 en este caso el
número atómico es 7 lo cual nos dice que
tenemos 7 protones verdad tenemos 7
protones en el núcleo del carbono 14
ahora bien si el número de masa es 14
entonces tendremos que restar 14 menos 7
para obtener el número de neutrones en
este caso 14 menos 7 serían 7 verdad
entonces tenemos 7 neutrones ahora
pensemos cuál sería la proporción que
hay entre neutrones y protones en este
caso tendremos neutrones dividido entre
el número de protones serían 7 entre 7
que es igual a 1 así que esto implica
que tenemos un núcleo estable esta es la
razón por la cual el carbono 14 hace un
decaimiento radiactivo ok
empecemos viendo que el número de núcleo
ness se conserva así que déjenme
utilizar otro
para ver esto del lado izquierdo tenemos
14 nucleón es cierto que en este caso
son 6 protones y 8 neutrones ahora bien
pensemos que tenemos del lado derecho
también tenemos 14 neutro el perdón
núcleo no es verdad tenemos 7 protones y
7 neutrones así que obviamente un
electrón no es un protón ni es un
neutrón los núcleo nes se conservan en
este tipo de reacciones así que del lado
izquierdo tenemos 14 núcleo nes mientras
que del lado derecho en este caso son 0
y en el caso del nitrógeno serán 14 así
que tenemos una conservación del número
de un núcleo nes la otra cuestión que se
conserva es la carga verdad y podemos
ver eso de aquí abajo verdad del lado
izquierdo tenemos una carga total de 6
mientras que del lado derecho tenemos
una carga negativa y 7 positivas lo cual
nos da una carga
6 positivas bueno tenemos una una carga
de más 6 así que tanto los núcleos se
conservan como la carga en una ecuación
nuclear y no tenemos que es lo que hemos
obtenido en esta digamos identidad
verdad fuimos de carbono y nitrógeno y
esto fue porque cambiamos el número de
protones fuimos de 6 protones a 7
protones cierto así que esta es la idea
de las transmutaciones de cambiar de un
elemento en otro elemento así que para
los núcleos con pequeños números de
protones la proporción entre neutrones y
protones digamos la ideal es que sea uno
a uno verdad para núcleos con más
protones resulta ser que esa proporción
cambia así que vamos a fijarnos en eso a
medida que incrementen incrementamos
protones la proporción para un es para
un núcleo estable va a cambiar así que
hagamos espacio aquí
un poco así que a medida que aumentemos
el número de protones la proporción
entre neutrones y protones va a cambiar
de hecho esto será igual a 1.5 a medida
que incrementamos el número de protones
así que si superamos digamos los 20
protones mientras más y más protones
obtenemos necesitaremos más neutrones
necesitamos más neutrones y podríamos
pensar porque digamos pensemos que aquí
tenemos un núcleo muy grande y por
supuesto esto es una caricatura móvil o
una representación muy pobre de lo que
es un núcleo pero pensemos en dos
protones ok
dejen usar otro color pensemos en dos
protones que estén por supuesto muy
cerca nosotros ya sabemos que hay una
repulsión electrostática débil aquí
entre estos dos
protones verdad estos dos tratarán de
alejarse debido a la repulsión
electrostática y también hay una fuerza
nuclear fuerte verdad es una fuerza
nuclear fuerte entre estos dos protones
verdad y de hecho sabemos que la fuerza
nuclear fuerte le gana a la
electrostática pero eso sólo es cuando
estamos considerando pequeñas distancias
si tenemos dos protones que estén
alejados por ejemplo que tengamos uno
aquí
y otro acá entre estos dos protones
todavía existe fuerza repulsiva muy bien
eso debido a que tienen la misma carga
sin embargo ya no va a existir la fuerza
nuclear fuerte y debido a que ya no
tenemos la fuerza nuclear fuerte
entonces eventualmente tenemos que
incrementar el número de neutrones para
poder mantenerlos unidos verdad si
aumentamos muchísimo el número de
protones aumentamos la fuerza
electrostática y llegaremos a un punto
en el que necesitemos mayor fuerza
nuclear fuerte verdad así que
necesitamos agregar varios neutrones
vamos a tener que agregar más neutrones
verdad más neutrones y esa es la razón
por la cual hay que aumentar esta
proporción verdad necesitaremos más
neutrones a medida que aumentemos el
número de protones así que a medida que
digamos pasemos el valor de 83 protones
digamos que tengamos al menos 83
protones ok entonces tenemos un número
atómico mayor que 83
digamos fuerza repulsiva electrostática
de la que hemos hablado es tan grande
que prácticamente todo el núcleo es
inestable y entonces tendremos
decaimiento radioactivo vamos a hablar
de esto en el próximo vídeo sobre los
tipos de decaimiento radioactivo que
podríamos encontrar